our first speaker is ishmael murphy from
university of toronto
you talk about generalized instrumental
inequalities
thank you very much thank you for
for coming here um and thank you for
including my paper during that amazing
conference i would like to to really
thank uh frederick that has been
organizing i am a long-term visitor here
since the so there are many different uh
workshops that we had and this one is an
amazing one and then i would like a
round of applause for thomas
thank you very much
i i was very exciting about this
presentation because initially i started
my bachelor in math and physics and it
was too difficult for me and a movie
start and start was too difficult and i
moved in economics right
and then i just came doing that workshop
and then i saw yesterday a lot of things
about physics oh my god that's coming
back to hunt my myself right
but you know um
i i think i have been working on
causality like in economics i am from
the economics department and one of the
important models that we have been
working a lot in economics is this
you know iv
type of structure this particular bag of
structure and it's something like very
important in economics particularly
because many of the structure that we
have seems to have this very simple
structure iv structure that structure
here where this is for us for example
the treatment think about college
education
and then has some impact on your
earnings
for example and the fact is you have a
bunch of confounding
that may affect your decision to go to
the college
that may affect also your earnings
one of the examples could be for example
the level of education of your parents
it may affect your level of education
but also the network of your parent may
give you better wage
better earnings and so on so so you have
this confounding but we want to extract
what is the causal effect of why
you know from why so what we have
usually we use this iv type of structure
where you're gonna say that there is a
random variable
z that's gonna affect the treatment but
will not have any effect on the
confounding and we're going to use this
to try to extract what is the causal
effect between d and y
the question is in economics we come in
front of my idea about what is the z
variables right and we are not in
agreement about what is the good
z variable right so it's very important
for us to try to have a good idea of if
we could test the validity
of that iv of that instrument one of the
person like just in the economics
department david carr got the nobel
prize this year
while he was trying to find an iv for
the treatment he used college he used
like distance to college
he said that distance college may be
something that's going to affect your
treatment but it's not directly related
to your earnings and many people
complain
because if your parents are really smart
maybe they're going to live close to
berkeley here and then you are closed
so maybe you're going to have some
confounding here and then many in
economics we do not have like this
intuition of testing the ig because some
of the first paper that was in the
literature say that the iv is not
testable
so you cannot really test if that
structure is valid or not
it's more recently with all those work
on pearl inequality you know bellman
inequality that now we start to dig in a
little bit into that literature right so
that's why i i want to talk a little bit
how to facified this type of model so
this is going to be basically what i
will try to discuss today okay and
i saw a lot of interesting things
yesterday so i will try to relate my
talk a little bit before of the
discussion that we saw yesterday but as
i told you you know i move away from
physics because i am very bad in physics
so
if i misinterpreted what you did
yesterday is my fault right
so what i will
try to do it this is basically a bunch
of like summary of what i want to do
here i want to derive a bound on the
average causal effect which is like what
is the causal effect of the d over the y
because because of this confounding i
cannot really uniquely recover that by
one gdp
so you might have a bunch of
distribution that cannot rationalize
this and then i want to know what is the
lower bound and what is the hyperbone of
my effect
and the bond that are going to derive
gonna try to generalize
different paper that has been trying to
achieve the same goal uh before as there
is like jamie there is menske in
economics there is back and forth so
there are many different
approaches has been used to derive
similar bonds so why what i will do here
what is like is a little bit new is
because many of those structures
use the case when the outcome is
discrete
and all those variables are discrete in
general not the latent one we do not
observe the latent one but they impose
discreteness over here in economics we
are really interesting to earnings
which is continuous
and this random variable variable also
could be distance to college which could
be continuous so the question is how to
generalize the structure
when you have y and z that is
potentially continuous if you think
about the presentation of eddie yes 30
and then this techniques of inflation
you could see that if as soon as you get
into the continuous space
you're gonna have a lot of possibility
of inflation right so this is the type
of structure that i want to get right
how to get you know in that very general
framework and that we want to do so
in that framework i will try to derive
what i'm going to call this instrumental
inequality i record generalization metal
inequality because you will see that the
inequality that they're going to derive
going to contain the pearls inequalities
it's going to contain some of the
inequalities that thomas and koto has
been and then the bunny one and also
it's going to contain the
what you call the chsh type of
inequality right and
now the question will be you will see
the inequalities are going to be a bit
complex on how to test the validity
because i'm going to have a lot of
inequality so i will discuss a little
bit about the complexity of that type of
inequality i think i spent 10 10 minutes
to just see what i will do
anyway let's see what it works so i will
start with the potential outcome
framework so instead of looking at that
bag
one and equivalent structure is to put
in the potential outcome framework where
i'm gonna call my outcome gonna be y and
the potential outcome gonna be y one and
y zero so y one and y zero are
unobserved and d is my treatment so if i
decide to go to the college this is my
earnings that are going to receive
if i decide not to go to college this is
my own exercise university right and
what you receive what you're earning is
a mixture of those two type of
components
now what i want is
my
random variable y
could be continuous so it's very general
case i gonna have my treatment i will
fix to be binary just for simplicity but
i will allow my iv to be largely
mentioned to be continuous right
whatever you want okay
so this is the structure that i have and
then i will impose some assumption which
is like my potential outcome here the
fact that i put what i call this
exclusion restriction say that there is
no channel that moves directly from the
earnings to the so here
you see i have no channel here
so this is the exclusion restriction
right so my z does not have a direct
effect
on my y so this is what i put as a
student restriction in
and the fact that i do not have any
channel between z and u
is the fact that i'm imposing that
independence essentially
so you could think my u here as just my
potential outcome y d
right in in the way of writing so you
could put just here
if you want y one y zero whatever as a
potential makes sense
good so now the question to me is
what i recall the average causal effect
is gonna be what's gonna be my earnings
if i decide to go to college minus my
earnings service decide not to go to
college what are my parameter of
interest that i am really interested in
so now
let me show how i will bond this
in the situation where my iv and my
earnings are continuous right i will
move from the discreteness that we have
in some of the paper so this is the
density function of this potential
outcome id
now what i will do
i will use
the independence because my iv
is independent of the potential outcome
or id so you could make could make this
conditional you have the equality here
make sense to us
okay now what i will do i will do a base
decomposition
so my potential outcome yd i will
decompose as if i am getting treated
difficult to do or if i am not getting
treated if i am not going to college
this is just simple basic composition
but this one is density
right because the densities we have we
have the positivity of the density
so this is going to be bigger than zero
so this left hand side gonna always be
bigger than this side
but this is gonna be true for all z
sensor
so if it's going to be true for all z i
can then take the supremum over z
and making the intuition about what i
saw yesterday when you purchased a
little bit the
the the alice and the balkans this is
the way that you could see the
interpretation here so i move the z
like in the different value but whatever
i move that particular z it should not
dominate this because of the potential
independence assumption that i am
putting here so the intuition is because
this one has only one channel
for d
moving these two match should not affect
this that much because all this effect
has to be translated by this particular
right so i gonna have all this density
should dominate this one every time
so what i will do
i could integrate over that density if i
am taking any boral sets any a belong to
the bore set of y
so let me take that integration so what
i will do let me if i integrate this
over a
i am getting the probability of y d
belong to a make sense
and i could make the integral here
over the same density so what i will get
i will get
a bound a lower bound for this
probability distribution and i do the
same thing for a complementarity and i
am getting an upper bound for my
probability distribution
that makes sense to you so this allow me
to bound
the conditional probability
of going to the particular treatment z
but if my model is right
the lower bond has to be always
lower than the hyperbone
and this is observable from the data
and then the question is is that always
true in the data this may not already be
true in the data
so if my lower bound in the data is
bigger than my hyperbola that means that
my model is wrong
and something is wrong in my
structure that i am putting here does
that make sense to you so this is a
simple argument that i will do
i will say okay if this lower bond is
lower than this and lower than this i
need always to have this one should be
always lower than this one
if you rearrange this you get that
inequality and this is exactly what
people call the pearl inequality when
you write in the discrete case
so if you say the outcome is discrete
this is going to be a probability you'd
say z is discrete you're going to have
the superman over z here and then you'll
get that inequality which is coming from
the bell inequality and this is the very
okay did that make sense so far
now the question is
we know well this pearl inequality but
beyond the pearl inequality there is
other inequality like the burning
inequality or like the cs um the c h s h
inequality so let me try to see how i
can get those type of inequality using
my little algebra that i have here right
so
before if you remember when i put the
independence assumption i put the
independence assumption only on the
single potential outcome not jointly
right now what i will do
i will put the independence for the
joint
potential outcome the fact that i will
put for the joint potential outcome
gonna give me a lot more power
and i interpret this as the outcome of
this
alice and bob type of situation that
you're gonna have right and then
i have the full independence here and i
am still have this exclusion
okay in some of the work for example uh
thomas like to call this the type of
cross-world assumption right because
this is a potential outcome if you you
are not graduating if the potential
outcome if you're a graduate is that two
different dimension where you are right
my point is this crossword assumption
gonna give you
additional power including particularly
the bony one and the ch sh type of
inequality
so how i get that
let me take y which is the support of
the outcome and because my outcome could
be continuous i will take any partition
of y
that makes you part of the outcome right
so let me take a partition that i'm
going to call a partition like bl so a
partition of the bulb partition so like
i'm discussing any
you know per chip that i can have over
above and then i will take a partition
also over alice any perturb way that i
could have like over the you know at
this type of outcome so what i will do
now i will write down the joint
distribution
between y0 and y1
okay you're like
now what is interesting to me
is again i am relating to this
uh inflation you know that i saw
yesterday right when you you you know
you you change the mode a little bit
because i'm gonna take all type of
potential partition that i could
purchase
for the alice and for the bob and i have
this drain distribution but because my
joint distribution is independent of z
i could put this one is independent it's
conditioning to z that makes sense
so now because i am putting this and
because i have the potential outcome
structure which you remember as this
i minus d
what's going to happen is every time
that i am taking the joint distribution
i start by y0
y0 belong to a
and y1 belong to b
that i am given over z what i will do i
could do the same base decomposition so
i will put the d
everything everywhere so it's going to
have
y zero
y one
tactic d is equal to zero
given z so we are very sloppy
and
y 0 y 1
z is equal to 1 given z
does that make sense just basic
composition
now this is a joint distribution
but the joint distribution is going to
be dominated by the marginal if i remove
this
and this drain distribution is going to
be dominated by the marginal if i remove
it
so this is what i am putting here
the
hyperbar right
now what i do
because this has to be true for l hot or
z
i can take the infinity memorizing
and i get that drain distribution has to
be lower to this one
so why is interesting and why is
sometimes i got the feeling that it was
related to what uh is that merger
dependency my pronunciation is very bad
about you when you were doing your
presentation yesterday because she has
this joint distribution
and then she's look at the level of
dependence that she could have
between those if you could allow perfect
correlation or not perfect correlation
right if you look at this joint
distribution
the well-known bond for the joint
distribution is a fresh shake hyperbar
right
if you are familiar with that
not really so when you have a joint
distribution
like
probability of y1 belong to a and y0
belong to b whatever this is going to be
always lower than mean
of this probability of y y belong to a
and
probability of y zero belong to b
this is what people call the fresh
hyperbar
it's correspond to the case where there
is a perfect correlation between those
two random variable
but here you cannot allow necessarily
all perfect correlation between those
two because there is this bound that is
observable
see what i mean so if this one for
example is lower than the product of
those two
you cannot allow strict perfect
correlation between those two type of
number okay so this restriction gonna
restrict my joint distribution that i'm
gonna have here and then i'm gonna have
like this upper bound so what i will do
i will do the same thing
i am integrated over this marginal
so get this one
okay i forgot something here
okay i messed up something here so what
i do okay forget about that right
look at this one and now if i want just
to get that marginal what i will do i'm
making a summation over the partition of
the body here
partition so i will always get my this
one going to be always lower than the
summation over the second partition over
this year
and what i will do i could do the same
thing also for
a complementary
and do the same thing and get the lower
bound of this and then the hyperbarics
so from the joint distribution from the
restriction of the drain distribution i
am able to bound the marginal
and that bond are different from the
previous brand that i showed to you
you remember about that i have been in
the previous so here i get information
from the joint distribution
so now how are you going to make use of
all those two assumptions right i know
that is very a little bit messy my
notation is a little bit messy but i
have two type of bound that i can
construct
i can construct the bond on the marginal
this is what i show you was equivalent
to the
pearl type of inequality and then i have
another type of bond that i construct
that is coming from the joint
distribution
right
that
but this is the same quantity that i
have in the middle
make sense to you
if my model is true that lower bound has
to be lower than this upper bound this
is what we have and this is give the
pearl inequality
but if my model is true also
this lower bound
has to be lower than this one too
if you do the max this is going to give
the bond inequality and it's going to
give the ch s8
i am french that's so that's that
sometimes i am saying that say you see
the ch you know sh type of like of
inequality
that makes sense to you so this is the
way that i am deriving that inequality
like from from scratch and this is true
for any
continuum
z or continuous y that you're gonna have
so you have like a b generator so what
they're gonna call generalized
instrumental inequality i'm gonna say
that
the maximum of that lower bond has to be
lower than the maximum of this upper
bound so this is gonna have
and if you do this you get what i am
calling
the generalized instrumental inequality
is that make sense to you that i can get
for any value of z
and any value of y in my distribution
now where things start to be tricky
is if you look at very well the bond
that i have here depend on the partition
that i decide to have
so my instrumental inequality gonna
really depend on the partition that i
decide from the beginning so if i want
to get the most information
to test the validity of my model i have
to go over all the potential partition
if y is binary you get everything which
is the back and parallel type of
inequality because everything is one
binary you get all the partition very
simple very simply
when y start to be continuous
start to be tricky
if i have a methodology to do that i
cannot tell you right it's something
that i have been discussing like with um
if richard like since i have been here
so if it is discrete it's good because
you must also have all this linear
programming that you could do then you
could put like in the linear programming
if your y is dispute or this is the
script you could do that well but when
it's continuous is a little bit
complicated to do the game so it's
something that i did not really
uh we did not really entirely show
like how
what we prove with my my one of my
quoted issues here is if y is binary
but the z is continuous
what i show you as a generalized
instrumental inequality is the sharp one
you get all the information that we have
and how we show that
we look at in the bond that we have we
show that any distribution that fall
down within that bond could rationalize
my data in the same way of the inflation
technique that you know you have been
discussing yesterday so i basically
for any distribution that fall within my
bond i construct a model
that exactly deliver the same observable
outcome
in the model but we did that
in the binary outcome case
and continuous z
using some things from the
you know the the optimal transport type
of technique that we we do today to that
but when outcomes start to be continuous
i do not have any proof for that yet we
do not have any proof for that and then
we are something that we have seen we
still thinking about that and that just
how i'm doing in term of time very bad i
guess
so
i have 40 minutes right
so if i have 40 i have 15 minutes more
so that's super that's fantastic okay
good so
what is uh
difficult
is this following things assuming that y
is continuous
and then i am fixing a particular
partition and i am not taking all the
partition of the potential transition
i gonna get a set of inequality
if they are violated i see that my model
is wrong
but if they are not violated can i say
anything
reasonable
again i was discussing with ellie
yesterday and i talked about the case
when the outcome is continuous and then
you say that there is an inflation
technique there is a way to do something
using the moment
right so you have like a moment
characterization instead of taking all
the distribution you could use the
moment and do that but let's think that
you do that for a minute
in that case if you do that you may not
you know try to cover some of the
distribution that does not necessarily
you know accomplish that money in that
case even if your inequality or your
inflation test fails
how should we interpret your result is
that your model valid
could you use it
or not
if that makes sense to you in economics
we have that issue because in many of
our applications y is continuous
and since we have dispersed inequality
and some of our of this paper many of
our of our colleagues start to use by
the inequality that we derive
and they discretize the outcome so even
if the outcome is continuous they
discretize binary outcome and they do
our tests
and when it starts rejected they say oh
my iv is good
and then they apply distraction
and this was very disturbing to me
because in the sense when we wrote the
paper this was not my i know that i you
know i did not
solve the problem we did not solve the
problem entirely and then it was very i
saw all this referee report and i have
to say uh i i like that people use this
test but you know
i cannot really i am not really in
agreement so i was trying to understand
we are trying to understand with my
culture here so how
we could interpret
if we do not use all the information but
we use only some part of the information
is that something that you could get
something
relevant to say to people or policy
related
so let me show you a simple design that
we did that
that gonna give a very bad answer to
this question and very big concern for
me and for my coder is we're going to
consider a very simple design
where the outcome is discrete
is binary just an indicator we're going
to have the treatment also is binary and
then we're gonna have this z which is
multi-value which is pic 100
we're gonna allow the exclusion but
we're gonna
permit some potential dependence between
z and
so we're gonna allow a channel
here
a correlation here
so because we allow this correlation our
first iv model is wrong
in the simulation in the data
so what i will do
i will construct the bond of menskian
robins
using only the pearl inequality
not the ch
sh and not the bonnie inequality and not
our generalized inequality just
the pearl inequality that has been
deriving
in manski and and woben's paper
to get what is the bond on the potential
so it's going to be the average here
of y1 if you decide to go to college and
y0 if you're not so my set of parameter
is
data 0 theta 1 this is my set of
parameter
so when i apply those bonds
this is the interval that i am getting
okay so what that really mean actually
if you look at
what's gonna happen i should have used
uh beta so think about here is theta one
and here is theta zero
okay so the type of interval that i am
getting here is
yeah i'm very bad
so let's do that so
think about something i say something
like something like that okay i do that
and this is what i am using the type of
you know
jimmy
uh minsky type of bar so i do not use
all the information just the pearl
inequality
and here
i do the same thing where i use
the ch and the bunny
but not this one
so i'm not using the all informative
boundary using part of the band what i
am getting i am getting a different set
and that set is gonna be
i don't look at the number but what's
gonna happen is i'm gonna have something
see what i mean so if i use a part of
the all information i am getting that
information if i am using another part i
am getting that information but assume
that i am a policy maker
and i want the result
to say if i have to bring my child to
school or not
and you come and you pink
the bell
the bond from like the pearl inequality
and you tell me oh the parameter theta
should be here
and the second one came taken over
and you say oh the parameter the
parameter should be here and the
intercept of those two are empty
you see what i mean so if i was doing
all the inequality together i will
realize that my model is wrong and i
will not use the iv but because i am
doing separately
i am getting some bounce and i tend to
interpret that bond as a good causal
effect does that make sense to you so
using a subgroup of inequality
which does not deliver the whole
information could be very problematic in
terms of interpretation because i don't
know how people should interpret that is
that make sense
to you so
here if i am taking the identify set
based on the ruby and minsky and i
intercept with the identify set using
what i call the the you know what's
the mass called the cross word i took
from his paper anyway and then you take
the emperor and then you you get the
empty the empty set does that make sense
to you so how to solve that problem i
don't know
i have just some intuition that i will
try to tell you but i do not have like a
complete um
complete way to solve to solve that
problem right because what i the warning
is
it's better as soon as you have a dag
type of model that you want to test it's
better to leverage all the potential
restriction in that model if you use
only your part of the restriction it
could be very problematic
if you decide to make a recommendation
based on this part of this okay so
and this is basically what i am trying
to to do this this question of finding
this
you know the most informative set
of inequality this is what in economics
we call sharpness
right and when the model is potentially
wrong we call that misspecification
so what i will try to do here i will try
in the very simple case of binary
outcome and binary treatment i will try
to give you one idea of how i think we
could solve this type of problem
right
so
what i will do is
attractively
my intuition is going to be the
following
is i have this one and i know that my
model here is wrong he's not a good
mother
now the way that it's wrong is because
it's violated either the whole
inequality either the ch sh inequality
or the body inequality
now my question is i want to learn from
the violation something
because the violation has given me some
information
that i have been imposing here in that
model so what i will do once i have two
type of restriction that i did here in
that model
i cross that arrow
and i also say that there is no arrow
here right
so let me try depending on the violation
that i have let me try to relax some of
the arrows so try to
generalize a little bit my dag
what i will do i will put
a potential arrow here
that's why now my model gonna have that
structure
because now my why it's gonna depend of
if i get assigned to a particular school
and also if i am my distance from that
school so that's gonna be what i want so
my potential outcome i'm gonna have this
particular structure
okay
the second things now is before i was
imposing that
my potential outcome was not depend on z
so i was killing this one
okay now i want to introduce this one
but how i will introduce this i could
introduce in many different ways
right
if i want to get rid of that assumption
i could do in a different way
economically sometimes we have intuition
we're gonna say that your parent
education for example is not a good iv
or your distance to college is not
necessarily a good iv
but
if you are close to college it will not
earth necessarily your ad your earnings
is that make sense so i can give some
kind of shape restriction
about the direction where the iv could
go it makes sense to you so here i will
assume oh okay my iv
is not a good one because he has a
direct effect but my direct effect could
be
positive in general
i am willing to assume this so i'm gonna
put the arrow here and put the sign plus
just to say that it is positive
make sense to you so this is going to be
my first assumption
and what i will do i will do a second
one for the different assumption if it's
the other direction so i will lay down
all the potential relaxation that i may
have from this one so another
possibility is to do this
is to take another arrow
and put minus
so what i will do
for each of those small piece first i
will start here and i write down
the testable application for that model
if it is wrong
i will cross this i will look at this
you see what i mean so i will basically
do
slightly by slightly depending on the
way that i have a rejection to try to
see if i can relax the model and my
intuition is to find the minimum level
of relaxation
that's gonna allow me to not reject the
mother
that does that make sense and you could
do this in the discrete case again
because it's very simple to say okay let
this binary in the continuous
i don't know how to do it
but let's think of a very discrete case
how i can do this type of scenario so
what i will do
my initial assumption which is the iv
model is assuming that all are
right
because if you say that this is bigger
and this is lower if you put those
together you have equality right
so the same thing here so if i am put
all the assumptions together this is my
usual iv model so what i will do i will
look at what is the identify my bound
if i just remove this
and what is my bomb if i just remove
this and i look i will look at all the
possibilities
does that make sense to you
if i do this this is exactly what what
what's going to happen this is in the
discrete what i have to say is in the
discrete case
all the inequality collapse only to the
pearl inequality in the binary so in the
binary z binary y and binary d there is
no c h uh
sh assumption restriction there is no
bonding restriction we do not have more
so all the restrictions that are going
to have gonna be the pearl inequalities
that are gonna have here
so what i could easily show
is if the first inequality of third is
violated it means that my assumption a2
is violated and a2 if you go back here
is the case when y1 0 is bigger than y1
so this one should be negative
see this arrow should be negative so i
could look at i could relate each of the
violation
to each of the potential assumption that
i have as soon as i do that
i could basically write down what i'm
going to call the robust
bounds because the new bond that i'm
going to show will never be empty why
never be empty because if my model is
wrong i gonna relax it a little bit
until
i get no violation of my mother
that makes sense so this is the way that
this is what we call the identify set is
the bound of my whole model so if this
is the bond
of my whole parameter if all the
inequality holds
then this is gonna be the usual back and
forth type of fund if one of the
inequality holds i relax the model and i
construct the bound for this one and
this is going to be corresponding to the
case when i have just plus
see what i mean and the same thing for
when i have minus and so the same thing
like that okay so if you do that
structure
this set will never be empty
right in that case and what you could
say to the policy maker you could say
okay
if you're in that situation
do the
estimation of this one if all your pearl
inequality are valid okay you are okay
if one is violated actually you should
there is a new bag that you have to
think about is that dark where this is
plus
right oh this is a dog where this is
minus you see what i mean so
in this simple case it looks very simple
and easy to do
but when z starts to be continuous
and y to be continuous you can you can
imagine all the potential
scenario that we could have right so
my direction that i want to take is to
look at very in the very discrete case
to see what we could do first by using
probably all this linear programming
type of approach but i do not have a
completely
general result for the
continuous case and then for the for the
continuous y and the continuous see that
makes sense so this is the end for me
thank you very much
thank you so so just to go back to the
logic that you had in this last step so
essentially you're making these
so i can see supposing zed's randomized
so so this
assumption is kind of not yes
it's not in question and then
you're essentially allowing for direct
effects that are z is affecting why not
through d
so
just so i understand the inequality that
you're seeing is is uh
that that's violated
so it establishes that there is an
effect uh there but but it is
at the population level right whereas
your the assumption that you're putting
in is at the individual level so i just
wanted to ask about it
this is a very good question so in the
two things in the very binary
case
i could do the same scenario if instead
of imposing the assumption that i'm
posing here what look was a little bit
stronger that what i needed
because i could have
put here expectation of y y y one bigger
that y one zero and then you could get
the the the the same result i think this
is what i should do to make a little bit
more
more
regarding your claim but it's still
valid as soon as we have this
the question is is that putting the
assumption at this individual level
versus the
aggregate level
putting more restriction that putting at
the aggregate level i don't think so in
the binary case
but as soon as we move from the binary
case i i am not certain
and that's really the case
just one other follow-up question so in
the setting where zed's an instrument
with many levels i mean so there is this
problem that people may go hunting
basically and they try to find two
levels where things aren't violated in
fact i think in the example that pearl
gives in his book yes uh
um compliance d is dichotomized and he
sort of checked through different uh
places where he could dichotomize the
and it looks like i i haven't
it looks like he the the cutoff may have
been selected to just make sure that the
iv inequalities weren't violated because
they're very nearly violated but yeah i
don't know if that's the case yes
actually in economics we do that quite a
lot
they could have seen many people in
economy they do that quite a lot because
what they do and that's why i think this
question of discretization is a very
important question that we need to solve
because what they do people are smart
right they give you the data only the
way that the referee want to see so they
see that this sets the college is the
con something that could be continuous
and then you're gonna see in some paper
that we say oh let's take a binary
variable if there's a college in your
state or not but because they try the
distance and they realize that it does
not work right
and then they discretize and when they
do okay maybe your college in your in
your
city when it does not work the same a
college in your county right now you see
that in many economics paper right
this and this and this and then people
basically disaggregate or aggregate at
the particular level
just because they are fishing a
particular identification and a
particular level to avoid the violation
of the list of this and this is a very
big concern right in that way because it
could get to this type of like policy
recommendation that i was um
very discarded type of policy
recommendation that we're going to have
and that's why i think it's an important
problem that we need to solve
so you know to avoid all this fishing
for
for identification as i can see
i think thomas may have inadvertently
answered my question in passing but i
was wondering in the story that you told
in the binary case how
you settled on a violation of the
exclusion restriction and not
that
that z was confounded but i think you're
just assuming subject matter knowledge
that z is randomized
this is a very good point okay there are
two things that i can say to you
i can try to say too to answer that
question the first thing is
i assume even if
there is indeed a correlation here
but i am decided to relax that path
the setter that i will show you will
never be empty
so it will never detect
that there is a potential violation here
so relaxing that part
completely gives a situation where the
iv is no longer testable
now what you what you could do is okay
if you are in the scenario in like in
statistics you can say oh this is purely
randomized like we use one particular iv
in economics is the
[Music]
uh the month where you are born
like uh because it's gonna determine
when you're gonna enter into college or
not this type of thing if you think they
are pure randomized you can say okay
maybe let's maintain this one and not
this one but it might be a situation
where i can do the analogous of this
i can cross this
and just allow
this but if i do this this model will
never also be
be rejected right so it is going to be
really depend now i am thinking about it
i am like a beijing person so depending
on the prior that you have on the
structure
i think you take one particular
direction to try to implement in the
model we do that a lot in economies but
we do not like to say that we are
beijing
[Laughter]
okay
[Applause]
right
foreign